conflict avoided is conflict delayed and
magnified and so
it was a cross-temperamental learning
process for me i had to learn to work
against my temperament in order to
engage in conflict that was necessary
when it was necessary we always worked
through our problems until we had
resolution
and you were very
uh up you were very persistent in making
sure that we
found our resolution and i don't know
exactly what that was about if it had
anything to do with your personality
well i think partly weirdly enough it
was a consequence of my dislike of
conflict i thought oh my god we have a
problem here it's an actual problem it's
going to happen every day or every week
or every month for the rest of our
bloody lives let's hash it out right now
despite the fact that that will make me
sweat and raise my blood pressure and
exhaust me because if we can actually
negotiate our way through it and come to
a solution we wouldn't have to have a
fight anymore yeah and that worked we
went through our problems and we still
continue to go through our problems we
don't
rehash stuff all the time no well we
made rules too and one of the rules was
and this has been a rule that tammy and
i have used in our whole relationship is
like
do not agree to something you don't
agree to because the worst thing is is
you negotiate out a settlement and the
person decides they're going to
implement it but really they're
resentful about it because they didn't
want to have any conflict and then
they're crabby about it every time they
do it they do a terrible job and they're
irritated about it and that lasts
forever
[Music]
mom and dad fancy seeing you guys in
nashville
we're very happy to be here hi michaela
hi this is fun yup this is going to be
fun uh we are going to talk about your
couple's report
which is part of dad your understand
myself personality report
system where you can join people
together and then see all the ways
that you either work or don't work
right right each person can do a
personality assessment at that site and
then they can join with their partner or
with anyone else they choose to have a
couple's report generated that outlines
their similarities and differences where
they'll get along easily and where they
might have differences and why those
differences can be useful
and so forth
so are you guys really comfortable with
sharing this with the world the
differences in your personalities
whether or not that works i mean
apparently it works fairly well you're
both here you're on the same couch
that's a good start
yeah well um
we won't say anything that we don't want
to share
but we've talked a lot about our
personality differences and similarities
and
and figured out at least to some degree
how to appreciate them and how to
negotiate in relationship to them
mom what do you think are you ready yeah
i'm ready okay
we're going to start with agreeableness
so dad
you scored 95th percentile in
agreeableness
yeah that's sad
and mom
[Music]
you scored 29th percentile in
agreeableness that's different
so
it's a little bit different so i guess
we should talk about
has that been an issue with having one
person significantly higher in
agreeableness than the other
well if i could start i think that
you want some difference because
you know you're
reacting to what's going on in the world
and you can
temper each other or
you know change the way someone is
seeing something
through
the lens of agreeableness and have a
broader idea of
interpretations of the world
so so
the utility
for me in having your mom be more
disagreeable than me is that
i tend to
give everyone the benefit of the doubt
at a fairly broad level
and tammy is much more
skeptical i would say of people than i
am and
that means that when there's someone
around who you should be skeptical of
she's more likely to pick that up and so
i like to bring her to meetings
and just as an observer often
because she'll report to me afterwards
about her
thoughts and her suspicions and then
i've learned through
sometimes painful experience to at least
pay attention to that i think tam might
have paid some price for her higher
levels of disagreeableness
though
think well like what well when you're
disagreeable you tend to say no
does that have anything to do with
extroversion as well though
yeah if you're enthusiastic you tend to
say yes
well we won't talk about my enthusiasm
yet we're going to get there yeah we're
going to get there no but i think it has
something to do with me saying
no and also wanting my own way
stubborn yeah i want my own way yeah
it also um
it it does lead to some misunderstanding
because
people low in agreeableness can be
kind of curt and snappy not snappy
that's not exactly right they can be
curtain blunt they're less polite and so
if you want to know what someone thinks
it's really good to have a disagreeable
person around but it's not like they
really go out of their way to smooth
things out so that there isn't
that's more than just this it's i i have
risk of like i'm i'm not volatile right
and i have really low and withdrawal
that's part of that yeah well that's
complicated that it helps a lot because
it means that you're less likely to get
upset
and so but i'm less likely to walk away
when there's a confrontation mm-hmm
right and that can be both good and bad
and that's hard on something scary to be
around it's it's hard on somebody who's
more agreeable how did you experience
the differences in our temperament mick
when you were growing up so i'm it's
funny because i'm in a lot of conflict
all the time but i hate conflict
it really bugs me i don't like it i
don't like firing people for example
i don't really even like disciplining
people even um i don't like hurting
people's feelings and i would say tammy
is less sensitive to that than i am and
that's not a criticism but
but
and this is coming from someone who's
also
i'm split with agreeableness right but
low in politeness mom
i don't think mom would hurt somebody's
feelings unless they kind of deserved it
right well i think and your i guess
description of what deserve
is would be different
yeah well i think your mom's judgment is
really good and i think she often
puts people in their place let's say
when they deserve it
and also she's also extremely
compassionate towards those who need it
but not towards those who don't so your
mom was unbelievably responsive to you
guys when you were infants so how did
you experience the difference in our
temperaments you and your friends and
at least when you were younger well when
people came over they used to
be initially afraid of you like oh you
know jordan but then when they got to
know you that would switch over to mom
so that's one example
if i needed to
get a yes from a parent i would probably
go to you
that was very sneaky and treacherous of
you
so was it was there a downside to that
the fact that i would be more likely to
say yes and an upside to your mother's
propensity to say
no
everything was so muddled together
because of how sick i was that it's
difficult to stay
so is it disappointable person more
likely to
tell you something that
they see as
um
an issue to discuss
that might be sensitive than someone
yeah definitely that's why it changes so
that's truth right that's the truth yeah
yeah well in the relationship
between
disagreeableness and truth is an
interesting one thing about disagreeable
people is because they're
in some sense a little bit more out for
themself and are more likely to bargain
on the part of themselves than on
someone else's part is that they might
be more tempted towards deceit that was
self-serving directly whereas an
agreeable person would be more tempted
to like smooth over the truth and make
everything nice so no one's feelings get
hurt yeah both those don't work out well
no well that's why it's nice to have a
dialogue yes you know right both those
don't work out well
it's also gone you know as your
differences on agreeableness and this is
true for all the personality dimensions
maybe except neuroticism
as your as the gap between you
when you're in a couple increases it's
also increasingly difficult for people
to understand each other because they
don't understand their motivation so the
agreeable person will be running around
doing everything for everyone and making
things nice and the disagreeable people
person will be more competitive and
blunt
and
well and less likely to do such things
and so
they can misinter misunderstand and
misinterpret each other
quite quite easily
so i'm going to just read a couple of
sentences so people can get an idea of
what you get out of this report because
this is
the amount
okay so you basically do the understand
myself personality test you get two
people to do that and then you can hook
it up online and
i told dad that he should be charging
for this
because i'm running his business and
this shouldn't be a free product
however it is a free product you just
hook up your results so if you've
already taken it you can hook up your
results with other people but there's
probably
how many how many words here
four thousand eight thousand like
four thousand words
it's a real detailed report well part of
what we did
we has we spent years building the
couple's reports
there's
probably a hundred thousand words behind
it because there's ten aspects that
people are compared on and then there's
five different groups you can fall into
uh you know way above average above
average average et cetera and so the
program generates the report based on
your
placement on a normal distribution
percentile essentially and so there's a
tremendous amount of writing and work
that went into this it's the equivalent
of at least two books i would say
we were going to launch it
with a relative fanfare let's say but
i got extremely ill and we couldn't
do that and so we decided to release it
anyway because we thought it was in
people's best interest and we're
actually pretty happy with the sales and
so but yes it's a major feature it's the
only personality test i know of and
certainly the only scientifically
validated test that actually offers
people a direct comparison with a report
based on that comparison between them
and their partner and we're hoping it'll
be extremely useful for people because
you need to understand that there are
temperamental differences
and you need to
understand what they are and then you
need to understand and appreciate your
differences and similarities and figure
out how to negotiate them very
complicated for people
so i think what we should do because
we're going to be seriously delving into
this i think i should kind of give a
brief overview of what it's going to
look like and then we get into each
trade so we just looked at agreeableness
agreeableness
breaks down into
compassion and politeness so it will do
a comparison between agreeableness
overall and then dad's compassion level
mom's compassion level to adds
politeness level mom's politeness level
so when he said ten aspects it does the
five uh openness conscientiousness
extroversion agreeableness and
neuroticism breaks all those into two
aspects and then gives you a comparison
it's a lot of information here and
that's based on an instrument called the
big five aspect scale which i developed
with my students particularly colin de
young who was lead author on that paper
and it's become
one of the standard
means of assessing personality
psychometrically in the research
literature and also has been used by now
tens of thousands of people online so i
think it's reasonable to say that
it's the best
personality instrument currently
available
in terms of the breadth and the detail
of its coverage and it's certainly the
only one that offers this couple's
comparison
so do you guys think i should just
like kind of burn through some of this
and you can stop me yeah well just that
you can just ask questions and yep that
would be fine so let's go too so we
covered agreeableness agreements breaks
into compassion politeness compassion
dad you scored 96th percentile and mom
you scored 48th percentile so some of
the
some of the information you get here
this is you you
are likely to be highly conflict diverse
because you'll be concerned about
causing your partner negative emotion
your partner mom is likely to be capable
of engaging in conflict and he or she
will be a bit less concerned about
causing you negative emotion so that's
one sentence out of you know a large
paragraph just describing the
implications of compassion as a couple
so i'm gonna just keep going and you
maybe mom too
comment if you want to comment about
what this kind of thing means
dad
well i had to learn to i would say
engage in conflict especially when it
conflicts with compassion
um i've been in a lot of conflict
the r and i don't find it pleasant and i
don't like upsetting people
at all it really bothers me
and uh but i did learn that conflict
avoided is conflict delayed and
magnified and so
it was a cross-temperamental learning
process for me i had to learn to work
against my temperament in order to
engage in conflict that was necessary
when it was necessary
and so
that conflict probably perhaps came more
naturally to your mother or with less
internal opposition
yeah i don't think it i don't think it
bothered me as much but we always worked
through our problems until we had
resolution
and you were very
uh obs you were very persistent in
making sure that we
found our resolution and i don't know
exactly what that was about if it had
anything to do with your personality
well i think partly weirdly enough it
was a consequence of my dislike of
conflict i thought oh my god we have a
problem here it's an actual problem it's
going to happen every day or every week
or every month for the rest of our
bloody lives let's hash it out right now
despite the fact that that will make me
sweat and raise my blood pressure and
exhaust me because if we could actually
negotiate our way through it and come to
a solution we wouldn't have to have a
fight anymore yeah and that worked we
went through our problems and we still
continue to go through our problems we
don't
rehash stuff all the time no well we
made rules too like
when we were talking about an issue it
might have been something as trivial as
who was going to clean up the bathroom
sink and how quickly after they used it
part of the rule was
we focus on the specific issue so you
don't get to say well you never cleaned
up the sink and you're always leaving
things around and you've done this your
whole life and you'll never change which
is a really bad negotiating strategy it
was like
okay
apparently we have a problem with the
sink that might have been because of our
differences and orderliness which we'll
get together it's like what is it that
you want specifically done about this
specific thing
and then we would negotiate back and
forth until both of us were satisfied
and we used to have meetings with you
kids once a week i don't know if you
remember somebody i vividly remember you
favorite why do you vote in a ptsd
because you wanted to go out and play
i'm just kidding yeah well
well we sort we'd sort out the week's
responsibilities at this meeting and the
meeting had rules which was well there's
some jobs that need to be done
and everybody has to play a role in
doing them so that nobody gets resentful
and bitter and you have to attend the
meeting although you can leave if you
get upset but you have to come back and
you have to abide by what you say
what you agreed to
and so
for the week so it was for the week it
wasn't a big ask right seven days but
that's a long time for a kid it is a
long time yeah well and and people
generally don't have meetings of that
sort and one of the rules was and this
has been a rule that tammy and i have
used in our whole relationship is like
do not agree to something you don't
agree to because the worst thing is is
you negotiate out a settlement and the
person decides they're going to
implement it but really they're
resentful about it because they didn't
want to have any conflict and then
they're crabby about it every time they
do it they do a terrible job and they're
irritated about it and that lasts
forever
so none of that so that's a good rules
do not agree to things you do not agree
with and if you're agreeable
you'll say yes and then you'll get
resentful and that's the bitter and
horrible underside of empathy
i could add to that too
if you're in a situation where you feel
like you have to say yes as an agreeable
person
um say you need some time
yes because i use that trick i mean i'm
way better now
i don't have issues with saying no at
all anymore but when i was younger and
more concerned about other people's
feelings i guess uh i started saying i
you know i can't make that decision
right now i'm not comfortable you say
i'm not comfortable making that decision
right now or can i have till tomorrow
yes yeah well that's not a trick i would
say that's a good that's a wise strategy
and we also learned in our relationship
often to discuss things
and then let both parties sleep on it
and if you go to sleep with the intent
of
further clarifying the negotiation then
you often wake up in the morning with
something to say
you know that might also cause further
conflict but is part of the means by
which you reach a peaceful negotiated
settlement
i mean tammy you remember when we were
first together we'd have a conflict
about some deep thing usually for about
three days yeah and then once a week
well and then yeah yeah for a year yeah
more than that even perhaps for the
first year yeah well often
i'd be trying to work through this and
it would be at night and tammy would say
i have to go to sleep now which drove me
crazy i'd be up like
persisting on the internal discussion
she'd be sound asleep beside me which is
extremely annoying
but she would very frequently wake up in
the morning
with something to say that was helpful
or with a dream that related to it well
those kind of
pauses that you take when you sleep
allow
it allowed me to
reflect and find out what i may have
brought to the situation and that always
helped
yeah well that was another thing we did
constantly too which was to try to
figure out
how you know
i would sit on the end of my bed and
tammy did this as well
when we were having a fight and think
okay
what stupid thing did i do at some point
in the in the
lead up to this discussion
that increase the probability that this
would be unpleasantly conflictual and
that's interfering with the solution
and man if you ask yourself that
question you'll get an answer and then
you can offer that answer to the person
you can say look
despite the fact that you're utterly
wrong and that this is horrible and you
should just listen to me
because that's what you like to think
you could say well here i figured out
something i did that was not optimal or
maybe outright wrong and it's
complicating it and so like sorry about
that and you have to mean that and if
you have any sense you do and then we
could progress yeah that was a great
strategy because i think it
not only deals with the situation at
hand but it deals with
behavioral
patterns that you've had since childhood
that
sometimes don't work anymore and
in the in the conflict you can see the
discord and you wonder what you may have
brought to it so then that can shed some
light on
past
um
behaviors and then you can update them
yeah
through the negotiation well yeah that's
a huge part of what you're doing in
negotiation is that update it's also the
case that if you concentrate on your
stupidity
you now have a problem that you could
solve whereas you really can't solve the
problem of your partner's stupidity you
know you can you can negotiate and you
can discuss it but really that's
well that's that's in their domain
so you should really pray to be
enlightened about your own ignorance and
limitations and error because
you can get rid of that
with good faith and and through
negotiation people are not good at
negotiating negotiating one thing too
you can offer your partner we did this a
lot too it's like
okay
looks like i'm in the wrong here
what do i have to say what words do i
have to say to you right now that will
satisfy you and you might think well
if you love me you know or you should
figure out the words on your own it's
like no i'm stupid you tell me all
wander through these words awkwardly and
artificially because i'm not very good
at it and maybe i'll get better at it in
the future you can give your partner
that gift right you offer them
conditions for your satisfaction what do
you want that also forces you to specify
what you want
you have to ask yourself like you're
upset okay what do you want well i don't
know fair enough we can talk about it
and then maybe you identify if it's well
i want you to suffer and then that can
pop into your head and you're like oh
maybe i'm contributing to the problem
too yeah maybe right yeah okay next
we're still in agreeableness yeah we're
still in agreeableness
you are high in politeness this is my
favorite aspect and you are low in
politeness so you scored 85th percentile
dad and mom's scored 16th percentile
right that's a big difference yeah baked
it there's big differences that's a big
difference between us yes yeah and i i
noticed this often when we had when we
were fighting
um arguing
because tammy would
say something so outrageous and impolite
and then she would top it with like
another thing that was even more
outrageous and impolite and then with
another and
they were usually
an impolite people can be very funny
they were usually so over the top that
it would make me laugh you know but it
was
that impoliteness that does cause
friction in our relationship because
she's more likely to be curt
and mom's pretty curt yeah yeah yeah and
pretty blunt and blunt and so you know
i'll try to do something nice for her
and she'll
say something kurt or blunt and
then you know that hurts my feelings and
uh but
but yeah well c'est la vie you know but
you're pretty damn funny and i think i i
like that provocativeness i'm trying to
be more kind and loving yeah well
i have a better relationship now with my
conscience or with my
intuition or my higher power i have a
better relationship and i'm trying to
because you know all of us have these
personalities were
given wrestling with and then you know
do i want to be that blunt well in some
situations yes you know but in a
personal situation with someone i love
well no
yeah i do i feel i don't want that
yeah and yeah with regards to this
distribution like we all have
temptations towards certain sins and
what we've been gifted certain virtues
that make it easy for us and it's really
useful to understand that
temperamentally like an extroverted
person
person is going to find it easy to be
social
but an introverted person is going to
have to learn oh i've been i've had to
learn a lot right and especially now
that he's a public figure for me to be
involved in that i've had to learn a lot
about being
in a situation with people i don't know
and striking up a conversation yeah and
you're getting good at that introverts
can get unbelievably socially skilled
but they have to learn it consciously
and that that that bluntness and
impoliteness i do believe that that was
part of what attracted me to you to
begin with because
you were teasy and there's a playful
element to that or they can be even
though it's like harsh play
right it's like playing with a dog who
might bite you but but but a playful dog
and i really admired the fact that you
weren't a pushover like ever since yeah
right
yeah someone taught us how to do that
they're pretty good at barking actually
broke yeah yeah yeah you inhale when you
bark
we can even pull down
you started this fiasco
okay i think
moving on i think that we should i'm
going to skip a couple let's do extra
version because we were talking about
that one oh yeah let's yeah um so dad
scored 98th percentile in extroversion
which is extremely high
and mom scored 88th percentile in
extroversion which is also very high
uh
so let's let's start with enthusiasm i
guess enthusiasm is fine you guys were
actually fairly close
92 percentile for dad
and 86th percentile for mom yeah well
that's one of the things that's actually
made our relationship
easy dangerous yeah
yeah both of those but the thing about
your mom is is that if i offer her an
adventure
she'll say yes yes that's fun yeah
because she's enthusiastic so for
example earlier this year when i was
still extremely ill
we started talking about this upcoming
tour in 2022 and it's a major
undertaking i think we've got 150 cities
slaughtered or something and
i what
well i don't know it's lots 100 anyways
wow um
and i asked her if she wanted to do this
because she seemed enthusiastic during
the discussion with creative artists
agency who was helping her enthusiasm
yeah and you know we she just about died
two years ago and then
like i wished i was dead for like most
of the last two years and
so and we had no idea really if i was
going to be able to manage this at that
time but we thought we'd better get on
with our lives anyways but your mom is
always up for an adventure and i had
faith too that you you would be better
as well i really did
yeah so that's been really helpful for
us because
my life has been pretty wild in many
ways and
but with a tremendous amount of
opportunity and your mom despite her
lower agreeableness if there's an
adventure to be had she's on board with
it
and you know you might think 88th
percentile and 98th percentile aren't
that different but
i if there were 100 people in the room
i'd be more extroverted than two of them
then that all but two of them whereas
your mum would only be more extroverted
than
one in ten so it's the difference
between one and fifty and one and ten
it's still a big difference percentiles
are sort of misleading that way but
because say if you have 98th and 99th
percentile
in extraversion the 98th percentile
person is more extroverted than 49 out
of 50 or
49 out of 50 but the 99 percentile
person is more extroverted than 99 out
of 100
twice so that's in some sense twice as
extroverted
i scored 99
99 yeah i scored 99 but i'm
way less polite than you and i think
that has a lot to do with
the differences here yeah that's the
temptations towards narcissism that high
level of extroversion and relatively low
level of agreeableness so you want that
moderated by conscientiousness and
compassion yeah well that makes a
difference too yeah that makes a
difference too
yeah yeah
so well and we saw this difference in
you and julian because
you could not not tell us anything you
told us everything and you always wanted
to be around people
whereas julian was more
reserved and he was certainly his
proclivity and this is his proclivity
was
to not tell us things to maintain
privacy and that we could see that when
he was
three two yeah we could see those
differences extremely those differences
are there extremely early
i was also a bit confused because you
said tell the truth like no matter what
yeah it wasn't a bad thing we thought
you could keep some of that to yourself
and that would be okay well it's a
tricky thing to figure out when you're
not saying something because you're
lying and when you're not saying
something because you have a right to
privacy
it's a tricky thing to sort out yeah
okay so extroversion breaks down into
enthusiasm and assertiveness
we did enthusiasm
assertiveness
percentile
dad
and 81st percentile mom i didn't realize
you were so
extroverted i guess there there's quite
a difference between 80th 88th and 99th
or yeah yeah and also you're extremely
extroverted and so by comparison your
mom looks less wow
wow
yeah that's just how extroverted you are
okay well there's a huge difference at
the upper ends of the distribution like
you think what's the difference between
99 and 99.9 it's like it's nothing it's
0.9 it's no it's the difference between
one and a hundred and one and a thousand
so if you got if you're at 99.9 and you
got 10 99th percentile extroverted
people in the room you would be the
noisiest person so and that yikes yeah
and there's no that doesn't that doesn't
diminish at the upper ends
yeah yeah and so assertiveness
i think part of the other part of the
reason why i can't engage in conflict
resolution is because i i will talk
about things yes as people may have
noticed maybe maybe yeah yeah and maybe
you also understand that having the
conflict now like you said
is going to prevent conflict in the
future and so it's actually more of an
agreeable thing to to have less conflict
which would be addressing it yes if the
in the long run yeah
but i find
you know when i do my podcast people
sometimes criticize me for interrupting
and that's this extroverted
assertiveness when when i'm listening to
a conversation
questions are popping up in my mind like
mad it's part of verbal fluency and
like i need to ask them i need to ask
them it's it's a real impulse and that's
deeply rooted temperamental impulse and
i've always been unbelievably talkative
right from the time i was
two i think they called me motor mouth
when i was a kid my cousin called me
motor mouth and that kind of caught on
so now that'll be a meme i presume
i wouldn't underestimate zoom too i mean
we're having a conversation you're not
interrupting and say there's enough of a
delay on zoom that you end up
interrupting when you're not well that's
especially true if you're assertive and
enthusiastic because
and this is tam's pretty extroverted but
you and i are talking more
and the reason for that is that
her lag to first utterance is maybe a
half a second longer than ours what is
negative negative one exactly yeah
exactly all right so i learned when we
were disciplining the kids i often
disciplined you guys first
assertiveness likely neuroticism well
i don't think so but
very funny but i i learned that if i
could just shut up for like five seconds
that whatever annoying thing was going
on would annoy your mother and then she
would
she would
intervene but if we just left it to the
natural course of things the the
relatively well the difference in
extroversion between us at least in
relationship to that was enough so that
i would end up doing most of the
discipline
that wasn't that what you remember
yes verified verified but verified just
as an impolite person would insist upon
it
[Laughter]
okay conscientiousness
dad scored 97th and mom scored 83rd
and then
let's break it down
i think
it breaks down into industriousness
and orderliness
and then dad do you want to give like a
two second
explanation of industriousness and
orderliness sure well
orderliness is associated with disgust
sensitivity
at the emotional level
and orderly people don't like things
that shouldn't be touching touching
they like things where they should be
they like everything organized they're
more likely to have a schedule
mess bothers them viscerally just like
disgust does
um
tammy what what's our scores there yeah
you can't talk about me yet we don't
have our scores up industry
[Laughter]
um
so you dad scored 99th and mom scored
96th
wow
cool but there that's an interesting
difference there too because that makes
me one in a hundred on that dimension in
her one and 25.
and so wow it doesn't make any sense
really does it what if i had it would
make sense
yeah well then
yeah
right and so like i left in my own
devices i would just work all the time
yeah and they're locked
and just lock you in there yeah
we kind of did that
in my office because we learned
no i learned do you go ahead and tell
you can tell that story you went when
you went to work you didn't want to be
interrupted so i didn't interrupt you so
you could be there for hours and hours
and hours
yeah and then i i'm kind of fascinated
by
how you can do as much as possible in
the shortest possible period of time and
that's always kind of a game for me and
that's associated with industriousness i
like to work i would work all the time
pretty much
i'm getting better at
leaving that with recreation especially
artistic recreation and i like to spend
time with your mom and you guys so that
those were
those were good breaks and i have a much
more balanced life yeah i have a much
more balanced
day-to-day experience
yeah that was especially true and that
was good for you
yeah definitely because you learned how
to do some things besides work yeah well
i also trained myself when i was in
especially in graduate school to really
work i wanted to see
i spent like five years
pushing my the limits of my ability to
work
and then i figured out how to pull back
a little bit from that because i was
exhausted
i think when you're young it's really
useful for about two years or three
years
to work yourself to the point of
exhaustion to find out where that limit
is and then dial back and when you're
young you can kind of stand it because
you're healthy as long as you don't
drink too much etc
but it's really useful to test that out
and so
these career obsessed people they tend
to be extremely high in industriousness
and it's a precondition for extreme
success in most endeavors
yeah it's like a game right it's like a
contest it's a contest yeah especially
if you're a little disagreeable too you
know so in order to leave university
that way now what's the difference in
orderliness between us
uh
dad you scored
this doesn't seem right
you scored 80th and mom scored 40 first
but mom was
i think it was more aesthetics than
orderliness that's what i think
so openness i liked beauty oh that's
interesting yeah i still i still really
like people it might have also been
something your disagreeableness probably
made you less attached to objects yes
yeah yeah
i'm not attached oh
well that's a yeah that's another thing
baby pictures baby books yeah
i went outside one day those if you want
that i went yeah i should just give them
to me like out of my house i went
outside one day and i had this one book
where i had drawn little figures in it
was like i'm you know however many
centimeters tall and this is my name and
i'm five and it was just sitting on the
sidewalk
my mom was cleaning house yeah yeah your
mom i think it is she doesn't love me i
think it is lower that lower
agreeableness i mean tammy's very good
at
at getting rid of unnecessary things and
i know that was you know perhaps not
unnecessary where's julian's it's not
audi what is that supposed to mean
but it does clear away the clutter and
yeah we've accumulated a lot of things
especially over the last few years and
your mum's ability to not get
sentimentally attached to things unduly
has been instrumental in us keeping our
environs
functional and hopefully beautiful to
the degree we've been able to manage
that yeah i don't know how old you were
when i got rid of all the large
suitcases
we could only have small suitcases and
you could only take that much stuff no
matter where you were going or how long
you were going for
and that was part of
who it was cluttery to have we didn't
have room for big suitcases okay no more
suitcases
yeah yeah they they tour just so people
know with a carry-on it's very
impressive these outfits
carry on
okay
let us continue
do you know what the
this stewardess said to the vulture when
he tried to bring three bags
onto the plate
only two carry-ons allowed sir yeah
i sent that to readers digest and i got
a hundred dollar check
that makes the story so much better yes
it does yeah well i really liked reading
just when i was a kid you know it was a
good magazine i remember seeing that it
was written in there for you yeah
i bet those are these people are gonna
be scrambling to get their hands on
those now we should have some of those
okay anyway just try to make money just
in any way possible
okay
we covered we covered extraversion
enthusiasm is fun assertiveness
enthusiasm that means to be possessed by
god by the way enthusiasm that you just
say fun instead
yeah it's a lot of positive emotion and
there yeah yeah extroversion is the
positive emotion dimension and
extroverts are fun to be around i used
to think that enthusiasm meant somebody
knew what they were doing but now i know
it's just enthusiasm yeah yeah
discounted them being like that's a
great idea yeah that's a great idea
here's the plan let's do it fantastic
yeah like oh wow okay you're really into
this that's where you know you're into
everything yeah exactly
every idea is good yeah well too much
enthusiasm makes you manic i've had that
uh that issue a bit yeah yeah it makes
you manic that's that so every trait
pushed to its extreme can degenerate
into a pathology and that that's true of
all of them you might think you can't be
too creative it's like oh oh yes you can
you see patterns everywhere even when
they're not there
so and it's very difficult for highly
creative people to catalyze an identity
because they're interested in everything
that's different than being enthusiastic
about everything you can be interested
in everything without thinking
everything's a great idea and let's get
on it or you can be both extroverts are
impulsive
so and fine yeah well and there's it's
certainly the case that you can have too
much fun one of the things that was
painful about having children was the
realization of how much time you spend
disciplining them because they're having
too much fun because they run around and
you know they get
too excited and then they wear
themselves out or they they trip over
things or bump into each other it's like
settle down settle down you think i'm
educating my children not to be happy
it's like
well everything has its limits
i'm happy
that's good
okay
neuroticism actually first quick
question what happens
in couples if you have one person who's
super extroverted and one person who's
not because that to me my mom and dad my
dad was probably as extroverted as you
guys because he was super extroverted
my mother was not super expensive yeah
he's still now he's 90.
and still funny yeah and he's the life
of the party man and he was the life of
the party in fairview yeah i think
you're doing this
i think your dad was the most
extroverted person in our town
it seemed that way yeah i mean he was he
was
and there was about three that was way
more extroverted than i was yeah way
more way way more i was always quite
surprised by his
enthusiasm and his his goal of just
doing anything and he was low and
agreeable super like low in politeness
yeah yes and he's hilarious yeah he is
yeah but you don't yeah and he'll tell
you what he thinks too man even kids
yeah like i told my kids
don't
do anything to annoy your grandfather he
will not forgive you
and you were good you were good but yeah
my mother was very quiet yeah
unbelievable and i don't think she would
have known anyone if it were it weren't
for my father because he
brought people to her and i don't think
she had
the
temperament temperament to bring people
to her she didn't
she didn't so thank god
that she found him and that he found her
yeah and introverts get worn out by
social interaction and they need to go
have a break fairly frequently whereas
extroverts get energized and so yeah it
was tricky for your mom and dad because
it was hard for them to bridge that gap
because your dad was always out
socializing and yes and your mom enjoyed
that and she thought he was funny but
she was very she didn't go out with him
and she didn't really go out and make
friends on her own either you know
through sports
and that's something that she did with
sports even though she was introverted
she could act out
something
but not yeah maybe more open yeah
because that can sometimes override it
right if you're an introvert but you're
high in openness well she was actually a
good athlete too so that helped a lot it
was a domain of competence for her
and that's a kind of social activity
right it's not sitting around talking
which experts will do it was
going on doing things with people
and so that's something for introverts
to consider too it's a good avenue to
social interaction shared activity
rather than
mere socialized conversations like
dancing they went dancing yeah
they curled together they golfed
together and mom went and watched all
the sports the dad did hockey and
baseball and so she was out with people
when he was doing things and then when
she was little older she was doing them
too
and did very well with him my dad
my mom is extremely high in enthusiasm
and my dad is very low in enthusiasm
although he's quite assertive makes him
a complicated character because he's
half extroverted and half introverted
and so he was difficult to understand in
that way but
it's difficult to rouse dad to
enthusiasm for any activity and
that's hard on my mom because she's
really enthusiastic and really and less
assertive although not unassertive and
so
that was has been a point of conflict
between them and their relationship
okay
neuroticism
so you scored 74th yeah i was probably
still pretty sick yeah i took this test
and i
so i've done this a number of times
throughout my life i know it says
clearly on the website you can only take
this once which is terrible marketing
yes i don't think that's true either i
don't think it's you go through life
changes you can do it again right but
you should there should be a gap between
the times you take it oh yeah you can't
just repeatedly take it till you end up
with the personality you don't have what
you want yeah for sure well that's
that's really why we built that portion
in there let's say just don't cheat if
you just repeatedly answer the questions
honestly because i did this when i was
young and it was pretty much the same
but when my depression went away my
neuroticism plummeted so the withdrawal
aspect too
um but also the volatility well
depression depression is a modulation of
your neuroticism in some sense and so
it's always been difficult for me to
answer the neuroticism questions because
when i'm healthy
i'm low in withdrawal and i'm low in
volatility but when i'm unhealthy well
both of that mounts up and so then the
question is because i've had some
repeated bouts of depression the
question is well
who are you
and dancers well it depends on whether
or not i'm depressed
yeah
so it's hard to answer um
but i think oh and this is you can tell
me if this comment is wrong but
i think people can get along with a
variety of different personality traits
right but if you have two neurotic
people yeah
i'd just try and find i remember seeing
my score and my score neuroticism was
like 90 something i was like okay the
only there's certain personality traits
i wanted to mate but i definitely can't
be with another neurotic person well
women initiate about 75 of divorces
and there are multiple reasons for that
what but one reason is is that women are
higher in trait neuroticism they're more
sensitive to negative emotion so they
feel more units of negative emotion
subjectively per unit of stress that's a
way of thinking about it and so they get
unhappy faster now
why is that well
the jury's out on that but some possible
reasons it seems to kick in at puberty
because it's not true for boys and girls
they're smaller their upper bodies
aren't as strong they're they're not
likely to win physical contests
especially with men especially with
tough men despite the marvel movies and
so
the world is more dangerous for them in
some sense physically but i think more
importantly
is the fact that
they are going to bear primary
responsibility for dependent infants and
if you have an infant depending on you
you should react to the world as if it's
more dangerous than you might if it was
just you negat navigating through it
so now the downside of that for the
people who have to live with women and
for women themselves is that they're
more likely to get upset they're more
likely to make a big deal out of
something statistically speaking
there's plenty of men who are more
neurotic than plenty of women but on
average which is the case that's just
the worst i'm just going to put it out
there that is the most
yeah well it's just
it's useful for men to understand this
you know because
women we got mom
oh michaela
that's extroversion talking away and
then realizing what she's saying
yeah yeah that's for sure
did you know side note shying away from
this um have you heard of the
vasopressin and oxytocin for bonding
which is really interesting so
vasopressin is released
when there's stress
and men tend to bond when that chemical
is released
so you which isn't that interesting so
you can stress out a man in a situation
and that'll increase
reconciliation bonnie yeah
but for women
it's oxytocin that's really involved
with bonding so what you want to do for
a woman is make her feel safe yes so
it's interesting isn't that interesting
they did a bunch of studies on voles too
shot them full of oxytocin and vascular
presence see what happens but that's
that's so cool so you can be more
neurotic you can get away with being
more neurotic as a woman if you're with
a man who's more stable
and potentially according to voles
that might even increase bonding if you
can if the man can take away some of the
woman's kind of problems and make her
feel calmer yeah well i think that's
highly likely highly probable that
yeah and so i think when i'm
healthy
i'm low in withdrawal and
a little higher in volatility but low in
withdrawal because i don't
you know
fear fear doesn't stop me from doing
things yeah mom so this i i would say
when you did this because you scored
80th and that's just not true because
you wouldn't do a a world tour and meet
all these people if that was the case
you just stayed home right you scored a
third yes i have no withdrawal
so we're kind of we're a little bit
the sex differences here
are
turned around yeah i know that's that's
yeah well and so that means that
when we
have a disagreement
for where whatever it is caused by
my need for safety being a woman
and your need for being
uh
having some sort of reconciliation
is is kind of backwards yeah well your
mom has a relatively masculine
temperament because she's low in
agreeableness and low in neuroticism and
i have a relatively feminine temperament
especially when i'm depressed
and so
and that's an interesting it's
interesting to consider that in light of
this cultural argument about sex and
gender
well there's there's two sexes let's be
clear about that and there has been for
several hundred million years so there's
actually no dispute about that but
there's a lot of variability
even biological variability at the
temperamental level and so there's
plenty of masculine women and feminine
men but that doesn't mean they should
switch bodies that's actually the wrong
solution to that problem
so
and that can be true even though on
average women are higher negative
emotion and higher in agreeableness
okay oh yeah so neuroticism i mean
the the one of the problems there is
that people are higher in negative
emotion and neuroticism
will tend
at least from the perspective of those
lower to make mountains out of mole
hills and so
it's a problem that you deal with in
clinical
practice a lot especially with people
are depressed because any failure
makes them think they're a horrible
unworthy person and that their life
isn't worth living and that's too much
of a reaction to every problem so part
of the way you bind that is you try to
make the discussion about the smallest
thing it can possibly be about
and i think that's a good guide to
political discussion as well
everything's not climate local local
local specific practical ah actionable
negotiable articulate articulable
yeah it's not arcade
articulatable yeah
i think it's articulable but maybe
[Laughter]
see the impolite person corrected me
dad's dad's right but you can also say
articulable huh i don't know that word
yeah so they're so they're girlies we
learned yeah we learned something yeah
successful podcast well that's me
enthusiasm asking
that doesn't make sense tell me about
that alone well that's that provocative
part too that's linked to a sense of
humor
most most comedians are low in
politeness
high in compassion though they may still
be they're low in politeness because
they'll say things that no one else
would say
and that's funny it's often funny
openness to experience
yep that's basically the creativity
dimension
essentially that's what peop
people think openness is like how
willing you are to discuss things how
open it's
it's not a great name the
psychometricians didn't nail that one
well but it's a hard one to get right
but you can think of it as
creativity and interest in ideas and
that's
otherwise it's
misunderstood yeah
so dad you scored 98th overall and mom
scored 68th
and that breaks into so when i scroll
down here actually i'll show it on the
screen but you can see behavioral roles
your virtues and faults as a couple and
that's under
all these different personality aspects
so intellect that's the first one it
breaks into intellect and then openness
intellect dad you scored 97 percent on
intellect
mom scored 34th percentile in intellect
and that's really interest in
semantic ideas i would say so people
high in intellect they're
philosophically minded they like
non-fiction particularly
um
men are likely to be higher in this
intellect than women although women are
higher in the other aspect of openness
which is more interest in aesthetics and
formal creativity and more likely to
read fiction and so i'm really really
interested in ideas although i'm also
interested in aesthetic experience and
your mom is definitely less interested
in ideas than i am because i'm obsessed
by them
oh yeah yeah you're obsessed by ideas
oh yeah
yeah you notice that some people have
noticed that yeah i mean when i was when
i was in graduate school
i was thinking about ideas
at an extremely rapid rate 16 hours a
day like it was non-stop the only thing
i could do to stop it was go lift heavy
weights it was the only thing that and
alcohol when you were a little kid when
i knew you when you were eight nine ten
you seemed very thoughtful you seemed
very
interested in the books that you were
reading so the whole
ideas had already had already begun yeah
i was reading like
i always went to bed and read i could
read a book a day when i was a kid
science fiction book usually but i read
a lot of nonfiction world book
encyclopedias and i was obsessed with
words i couldn't tie my shoes up if the
shoes were on a newspaper
an old newspaper
you know sitting in the porch i'd stop
and while i was telling my shoes i'd
read all the newspaper articles my
brother was the same i used to do that
he couldn't get in the house because
he'd kneel down take his boots off and
there he'd be reading this
man words words and combinations i
haven't seen before yeah yeah yeah
so
okay so and then there's open then
there's the other aspect of openness and
what's the difference is there uh 96th
for
dad and 87th for mom yeah and that was a
pretty good point of contact for us too
for a long time i was obsessively
investigating and buying art and i
bought like 400 paintings but i whittled
them down from a
sub sample of
a larger sample of say 4 000 so i'd go
on ebay and look at like 2 000 paintings
in an evening which you could do on ebay
which was really cool and
i got so the good ones what i thought
were good would sort of pop out at me
and then i'd print them out and lay them
on the floor and your mom would come in
and with her unsentimental and
judgmental eye and slightly less
interest in aesthetics
we would go through them and i would ask
her okay there's 10 here
get rid of the worst one
and she was very good at that yeah it
worked really well yeah she liked that
she liked that well she also
yeah because if you like them all you
have to get rid of them yeah i'd already
pre-screened them you know but i wasn't
going to buy 10 a night i only wanted to
buy four a night
yeah so but that worked out really well
and it was interesting too because your
mom was kind of worried about my art
buying obsession which lasted about
three years could have been more worried
about it yeah but
generally when i came brought her
upstairs to look at the
paintings
she'd say well i don't like that one and
i don't like that one and i don't like
that one but you could get those other
three and that was enthusiasm plus her
interest in aesthetics and so
that's funny yeah
okay well and that's a good one i think
it's really hard for couples where one
person is really high in openness and
the other one isn't that's a hard gap to
bridge man because
the one person is going to be really
interested in ideas and in art and
literature and music and all of that all
of the whole artistic realm and the
other person
isn't
isn't struck by that or consumed by it
and
i don't know how to mediate that
well that was good for us for sure yeah
it really made fun for us
i mean my mom is lower in openness than
my dad
and art scares her
especially if it has to be nice like
she'd have her house covered with
kittens if that was a possibility in
fact she does to some degree
i bought some rough russian
impressionist paintings from an artist
that i really liked in the soviet union
and they were selling for like nothing
they were next to free i bought my dad
10 of them which i really liked and sent
them to him and
he liked them a lot but mom wouldn't let
him hang them up upstairs
i think they were too
unsettling for her
but he eventually got them framed and
then brought them up sort of one at a
time and she got accustomed to them and
then liked them and then years later
probably 10 years later when i reminded
her of the first part of the story she
didn't remember it at all she really
liked the paintings by then but it took
her a long time art is quite terrifying
you know and if you're naturally
attracted to it that's one thing but
beauty is no small force man and
so
for people low in openness they're not
attracted by
the aesthetic experience to such a
degree and so it's kind of unsettling
for them
so
and that's a tough that's a tough i
remember i went to visit my dad and we
had gone to vancouver and i said let's
go to the emily carr museum
why would we want to do that he said he
wasn't very high in openness but what
makes you think that'd be a good idea
but i think
what about this though if you have
someone who's extremely extroverted
though
then wouldn't that just override it
because even even going around no no
they just want to go there because to be
part of the crowd and have fun yeah yeah
but they don't they don't care about the
art
yeah but the museum would have to be
full of people
yeah they'd go to a party at a museum
yeah but they wouldn't go imagine the
museum was empty and they had to go
there alone like oh yeah i'm extroverted
but i would go to a museum alone
i'd rather go with someone but i would
go alone yeah and i go to movies alone
see i don't yep i like movies alone as
well
yeah
i think i've had that issue a bit when
i've been traveling and i like to go to
parties when i'm the only one there that
i don't know anybody else there i used
to do that all the time when i was in my
twenties you know around the university
and i'd find a party and i'd walk in the
house and be in a party with people
didn't know anybody low and withdrawal
yeah yeah yeah that's part of your part
of your basically yeah i was like oh
this is interesting
that was disrupted for you to some
degree by the pill
well the pill yeah the pill was terrible
it made me depressed and volatile and
volatile but thanks to everybody like no
one says
everybody depressed and volatile i still
had no withdrawal though it upped my
volatility but it didn't change no no it
didn't so that's interesting it doesn't
make everybody depressed i had clients
who were depressed especially with pms
like they had cyclical monthly
depression and for some of them the pill
smoothed that out substantially so
you have to pay attention to individual
pills
i know it wasn't good it was terrible it
ruined a lot of people i didn't take
care of myself i didn't take i didn't
cut my hair i didn't take take proper
care of what i was wearing and stuff it
really depressed yeah it was really bad
it was really and you're not prone like
that's so wonderful it was chemical yeah
you're not prone to depression like that
no
rebecca is like
unbelievably bubbly not prone i would
say at all same thing as soon as she
went on the pill
uh she was crying every day yeah that's
a massive difference and people are put
i'm not happy with that people are put
on that when they're like 14 for safety
when your emotions are all
topsy-turvy anyway and they're like and
then it takes a couple weeks to make you
depressed so you don't really notice
right away and then you're on it for 10
years before it's like oh
you know
or longer 15 years because apparently
it's safe to take forever anyway i
started taking the pill when i was
16 years old
i finished i
definitely had way more trouble with my
parents for the last two years of high
school so i think i changed dramatically
and then i went off to university you
changed around that time and i went off
the pill
went to university went back on the pill
dropped out of university
and i was you know meeting boyfriends
and so i would take part in
goal directed
when i was not on the pill and then as
soon as i was on the pill i'd drop
everything well it was terrible after
michaela was born
no julian
yeah that's right after julian was born
we were getting along pretty well and
you weren't going down the pill i went
back on the pill when julian was a year
old yeah and i just my i was completely
different person
i was completely different person and
luckily someone came to visit who said
the same thing happened to her
and so i stopped taking them and then i
then it was fine yeah it was quite
dramatic it was quite dramatic anyways
we shouldn't talk about that too much
yeah yeah no but birth control pills and
yeah they're going to get along
yeah right
can we well we went over the personality
report yeah so people can go to if they
want to do that they can go to
understandmyself.com
yeah it's dirt cheap it's we tried to
make it ridiculously cheap we tried to
make it we had 9
we had rules for the company we wanted
to only sell
we wanted to sell because we wanted to
make sure we developed the personality
tests and also the self-authoring suite
which helps people write about their
past present and future we wanted to
only offer high quality scientifically
validated
interventions that were self-directed
for people so they had to be based on a
solid research background we didn't want
any administrative overhead we wanted
people to be able to do it on their own
we wanted to make it scalable ultimately
and we wanted to keep the price as low
as possible and so those were the
and the saleability issue is think about
it this way you develop a personality
test but no one uses it
well that's not a good solution to the
problem you want to have people use it
so then and then you want to have them
use it and be happy enough about it to
pay for it because that's actually a
mark of its utility
so we instituted my partners and i
doctor robert peel who was my graduate
supervisor and dr daniel higgins who was
an is an mit trained engineer and was my
student at harvard who i've been working
with now for 20 years we use those
principles to guide the development of
all these tests and that's worked real
very well so far
website's a bit wordy but we're working
on that now
so anyways yeah understand myself um
it's been i think
you know even though
well when we were first working on the
test we gave it to kids
yeah that was really useful they were
young young yeah six years grade six
yeah five or something i remember that
like super young you had to self score
it
yeah and i realized because oh yeah it
didn't work for them at all kayla and i
would get into tussles now and then
um
and i realized after reviewing her
personality scores that it wasn't
because she was low in agreeableness
because i i thought she was pushing back
but it was because
partly because she was ill she was
volatile and she she'd get upset when we
were discussing things not because she
was rebelling or pushing back but
because she got upset and so i tried to
learn when she was upset not to get
upset about that in return but to give
her a hug or a path and to understand
that it was emotional upset rather than
you know rather than a motivated
rebellion that was really helpful and i
learned too that
julian was extremely easy to get along
with
um
yeah and it wasn't because he was
agreeable because he's not agreeable but
he's really emotionally stable really
low in neuroticism and so
and when in retrospect i thought well
that makes sense because
if he said no you couldn't get him to do
it like really really when when he was a
little kid
when he was a little kid he used to say
yes in school sometimes but not do it
yeah just didn't want to be bothered by
the people who were yes shut up so i had
to explain to him i said you know there
might be other kids who want to do this
you've said yes you've got you've got
the right to do it but now you didn't do
it someone else didn't get to do it so
just say no and get on with it well now
he just says no very easily yeah when he
was that used to confuse me
yeah confuse me hey can you help with
this no yeah what do you mean you can't
like i don't really want to help with
this either but i'm helping with it
because the other person needs help
you're just saying no what are you doing
sitting at home like
i want to be sitting at home when he was
about
11 months old he had this
tippy cup
and he used to we'd fill it with water
or milk and
and give it to him and he used to dot
make dots everywhere with it and when
that was milk that wasn't such a good
thing so we tried to get him to stop
doing that and we finally had to take
the cup away because there was no way he
was going to stop doing that and he was
only like 12 months old 11 months old
and i had a battle with him one time
when he was learning to feed himself
because he had taken the spoon from his
mom he wasn't going to give that goddamn
spoon back and then he wasn't eating
because he'd just eat a bit and then
he'd play he's playing hockey yeah he
has played hockey that's right and then
he was getting too hungry and then he'd
get crabbing he wouldn't nap and then he
was upsetting his mom and i thought all
right kid i'm taking that spoon back
because i'm gonna feed you and
it literally took me three hours
fighting with this like 10 month old it
wasn't really a fight though it was
really ingenious so he'd poke him in the
shoulder a little bit and julian would
be sitting there with his mouth shut up
just try to feed me and then he'd poke
him a few times and he'd go
and then you stick the food in his mouth
then he tried to push it out with his
tongue
airplane mode yeah
i thought it was on april airplane but
apparently it isn't let me fix that
right real quick
so yeah yeah it it well it got so
intense this fight that your mom had to
leave the room because she couldn't
tolerate the conflict and i it was
making me sweat too but i thought
there's no damn way this nine month old
kid is gonna win i was patient like i'd
learned at that point when i was
disciplining you kids to
not
usually not get upset it was just like
no
on the steps with you you stopped doing
that when you're
willing to
behave like a civilized human being you
can come back that was the rule right do
something disruptive yeah you remember
those words well
you
you were pretty easy to discipline
because very easy yeah very you should
have known you were agreeable yeah all
we had to do really was say no and we
didn't even have to say it very harshly
you'd just stop i think i i scored
50th percentile because the compassion
was at 88. okay brightness isn't like
low but julian when we used to put him
on the steps man
he would just sit there and rage like
his fists clenched his jaw are you ready
yet he'd say oh no
but he was trying to get himself under
control yeah we'd go over there and this
was he was very young i remember just
being sad are you ready to get off the
steps no i'm not ready yet
and then he'd get himself under control
it was really interesting to watch him
build that
internal apparatus to control you know
to control that and he got extremely
diplomatic because he was so
disagreeable but because we were
disciplining him he would just worry
that edge like how much can i get away
with exactly precisely right now and
your mom and i would watch this because
especially if he went to daycare and
interacted with some kids who were full
of tricks he'd come home full of tricks
you know he'd try them out let's try
this out and see if it works
and so it does that yeah yeah yeah yeah
well it's it's a signal it's a sign of
the imitative instinct
yeah
no one likes that kid
that's right stop being that kid yeah
and so tammy and i would talk because we
tried to present an integrated
disciplinary front we weren't going to
let you kids play one of us against the
other although imagine you'd manage that
some of the times and we'd say okay
julian he's getting out out here we're
going to crack down on him for two weeks
he doesn't he doesn't get away with a
whisper out of line and so we'd really
like attend to him right watching it if
he ever did anything out of the line it
was like stop and what was really
interesting this was so interesting
every time we did that
he liked us way more oh yeah yeah it
comes for attention yeah it's not chaos
right right got some boundaries they're
not just like well how far can i go yeah
oh i have a story i have a story so when
we were in boston i was taking care of
these little kids one afternoon
someone's
someone's care worker had a car accident
and they didn't have someone to take
care of him and i had
your friends that used to come over and
play all the time so i had this troupe
of kids in the house and so this little
guy came in and he was about three years
old
and his mom said don't worry he won't
eat anything but you know just keep him
for the day and i thought well that
doesn't make any sense so don't worry he
won't eat anything yeah so at lunch time
we sat down we had chicken pot pie and
you guys
knew that you had to eat and so did the
two kids always came they knew yeah
except that one kid
he'd only eat hot dogs at home
mitchell yeah was that right yeah but he
ate everything at our house probably
knew what was that yeah
oh i didn't know that yeah
anyway this little kid sat down and he
wasn't going to eat anything but we did
the same thing
we did with julian yeah except i used
more reward and then he would eat
something and we'd go good boy
we tried to feed him something eh yeah
and he was about he was about four he
might have been four he might have been
four we tried to feed him something and
he'd go like this yes and i thought well
that's what that's what a nine month old
does it just move his head i thought oh
this kid hasn't been interacted with
since he was nine months old yeah and so
i just keep the
spoon in front of him and with a little
bit on one finally he'd he'd eat it and
then i'd go pat pat pat
you did the feeding not me that was you
that did that yeah yeah and you were
there i was watching that's right and
you kept rewarding him and then it was
so interesting so
when i had come home that day that kid
was standing in the porch by himself
looking miserable while the other kids
were playing and i came in i looked at
him i thought
what the hell that's not good and so
then i poked him a bunch you know to try
to play with him and he just went like
this he was sullen and he had no idea
how to play and so that was really sad
and then
lunch was after that anyways tammy fed
him and he got right to the bottom of
the bowl
and finished it and she said
look you finished it look what you did
and he just
lit up into a huge smile oh that's gonna
make me yeah oh it's worse it's worse
it's worse he wasn't toilet trained yet
yeah he followed tammy around for the
rest of the day like a puppy like he was
right on her path and then yeah when we
sat down we used to go downstairs and
watch disney
and and he sat on my knee he climbed
right up on her and grabbed her like
that like that little monkey clinging to
the wire mother in the famous
experiments and then jesus christ his
mother came home and came downstairs and
she saw
tam hit this kid clinging to tammy and
she said oh super mum and grabbed him by
the hand and laughed it's like that's a
horrifying story yeah yeah well she was
a psychologist too so just to put
another i think
he was a psychologist okay whatever yeah
no he wasn't
yeah yeah anyway i hope that that day
wasn't enough to really help them help
him some well yeah right or just make
them hate you yeah and take it out on
the kid yeah yeah which they definitely
would if it's like how dare you show
attention
it was something man yeah well they one
of the kids we babysat there too
this kid the one that wouldn't need
anything at home he was actually a
pushover this kid he wasn't tough he was
lovely he was a nice kid but one day he
had a temper tantrum in our house and he
could have a temper tantrum until he
turned blue
breath till he turned blue
try that at home folks and see how much
willpower that takes well he was having
a tempered tantrum in the kitchen
and he held his breath and turned blue
we just left no we put him on the stairs
and he woke about the stairs and there's
no one around it was like oh that was a
lot of work for nothing anyways he
didn't have any temperatures he couldn't
do that oh yes well i didn't know that
he could do it it's amazing
it shows you how much will there is
there you know and you want that will
directed and and disciplined and all of
that got spent on
passing out yeah yeah exactly yeah not
spent on counterproductive activities
okay well we went through everything uh
okay do you
what do we
talk a bit about the united disciplinary
front
i mean tammy and i agreed that we were
going to
discuss our disciplinary strategies and
and implement them and watch each other
you know because
you need two people to do that because
sometimes you're in a bad way we didn't
really disagree on that
just so i know just like we could clip
this or something it's this is just how
to work with your partner to disappear
properly yeah yeah well
and one of the advantages to that and so
we didn't let you kids and this i turned
this into one of the rules of my book
well first book don't let your kids do
anything that makes you dislike them and
that was a rule in our household it's
like we're not going to dislike our kids
period we're going to not only love them
which kind of comes along for the ride
at least to begin with but also like
them and so we never let you guys do
anything that made us
displeased with you for any length of
time and one of the great advantages of
that
was that we could take you to
restaurants even when you were very
little and so you were much less of an
impediment so to speak to our social
lives than you would have been otherwise
we could only keep you in the restaurant
for about 45 minutes to an hour when you
were little you know garlic have you
seen her in restaurants yeah she's she's
sitting there for two hours yeah she's
great yeah scarlett's very socially
appropriate well she doesn't have any
sugar in her diet that helps i think
yeah she's not hyperactive at all yeah
no she doesn't have a neediness to run
around yeah but she's you've done a good
job but she's playful yeah she's very
playful she's very alert and
she's very socially appropriate and
that's such a gift to give your kids
because then people used to come over to
our table all the time
because we'd sit they'd look askance at
us when we came in with little kids it's
like oh my god this is going to be a
terrible show and then you'd sit there
like civilized human beings for you know
up to an hour
and people would come over and they'd
they were smiling at you and looking at
you in a pleasant way really positive
reinforcement for you guys and you got
to come with us to other people's houses
often because you were well behaved we
got invited back yes that's right we got
invited back yeah yeah yeah if you go
over to someone's place with your kids
and you don't get invited back well it's
probably either you or the kids
definitely you but yeah
it's the kids it's also we had times in
restaurants in boston oh you'll remember
this one in boston
where you would misbehave in a
restaurant i'd just take you outside
often it was winter and we just stand
there it was like okay kid here's your
options we can stand here in the cold
which i can probably tolerate more than
you for as long as necessary or we can
go back into the restaurant and act like
civilized human beings what do you want
restaurant please
so do you remember the time in toronto i
don't know if it was you or julian but
i think it was julian we went into a
donut shop to get a doughnut and he was
misbehaving in some manner so i just
went outside with him
no no i put him outside twice there was
twice oh there's twice i put him outside
i was sitting right in the booth i put
him outside it's like
you can stand out there until you're a
civilized human being and this woman
just got she got so upset about that
that she literally once he came back in
she literally went outside
and put her butt against the window and
shook it back and forth
and then laughed it was like
how dare you try to make your child
you know act like a civilized human
being so people like him yeah it made
her very upset made her very sad nice
show and comforting upset yeah you could
tell that story i remember one horrible
story so i was on methotrexate and
naproxen which completely obliterated my
appetite in the morning i was nauseous
in the morning so dad used to kind of
force-feed me yeah which was very just
as unpleasant as it sounds yeah it was
awful we were at a we're at a a stop
going to the big apple the big house
that's right away from toronto to
montreal yeah and it was lunch or
breakfast lunch and we were sitting at a
table and i was like i'm not hungry i'm
not eating you know i wasn't very i was
probably nine or something and dad was
like oh no you're eating this yeah right
and it was just that's just mom and
julian left yeah we went because it
wasn't pleasant you know because you
weren't hungry at all we didn't fight
about it exactly but you were not
motivated i was upset yeah of course you
were sad yeah but you had to eat because
you were already losing weight and they
told us you your kid has to eat or she's
gonna wonder what have happened if we
would have just given her some meat
jerky i used to ask for jerky for
christmas yeah yeah but but anyway the
one well we didn't know yeah yeah well
obviously how would we have known yeah i
was speaking obviously okay no not
obviously i mean and encouraging you to
eat yeah i wasn't force-feeding you i
wasn't prying open your door i feel like
i
yeah well the rule was you you had to
eat your lunch because well i was losing
weight yeah you were losing weight and
this woman came over and she said she
sat behind i remember
she was sitting behind me you were
feeding me from here and she turned
around and and just like berated you and
i can remember that made me so angry
because i was like
you have no idea what's going on here
even i knew that i was only nine i was
like how dare you interrupt this yeah
well you you knew that you needed to eat
but it's not easy to eat when everything
tastes like cardboard and you're not
hungry and it's not it's not easy to eat
at all and you were too young to
take that on to yourself by that time
you were giving yourself your own
injections so
do you remember how that happened
i do
i remember i missed this whole simpsons
episode
yeah i can remember like having the
needle and being like ugh can't do it
the simpsons is playing downstairs
you had to have a needle how often a day
twice a week twice a week and so we were
administering it but that was scary for
her because needles are scary for little
kids yeah it was also the alcohol made
me nauseous
and because the methotrexate had made me
nauseous in the morning and it was
yellow when i was swallowing it and the
injection was yellow i had nausea
associated with that color yellow so
when i gave myself the injection it'd
make me nauseous because i'd already
associated nausea with yellow it was
just yeah so i used behavioral
techniques on with michaela to help her
learn to
inject herself because we thought it
would be better she had control over
that and so she was motivated by money
like and she still is um and so i and
she knew what money was by that
point quite sour keys yeah
yeah she knew what it could be exchanged
for and so i told her that if she could
do the injection i would give her 50
dollars
and
that was quite a lot of money at that
point
and so she sat for 40 minutes i would
say on the stairs with that needle
poised to inject and fighting with
herself and
and then kitchen table and then did it
and then i i think the next day it was
i'll give you like 40 dollars but you
have to do it in 15 minutes and then we
whittled it all the way down to five to
five minutes
or five dollars
five it was five dollars i got five
dollars every time i gave myself an
injection yeah for for a long time i was
like
like 17 or yeah yeah well we wanted that
you know we wanted to sort of balance
the scales a little bit and
but you got so you were extremely good
at it it was way better it became
you know part of the daily routine it
wasn't a big deal you weren't afraid of
it anymore and it was under your control
really needed to be well yeah you should
it was a lot better though it was a lot
better yeah
yeah
as good as that can be um yeah it was as
good as it can be and sometimes that's
enough to
make all the difference
well
is there any like i have more questions
but we've been going for
an hour and a half i think is
time to wrap up yeah that's pretty cool
you can always do another one later yeah
okay well that was fun yeah we can see
how people react and if they have
questions
then at some point we could ask answer
specific questions about relationship
difficulties along the given traits yeah
that's a good idea that sounds good well
thank you guys that was fun yeah thanks
it was fun
[Music]
you